- Hi.
(audience cheering loudly)
I'm so excited!
(The Chicks laughing)
I was feeling a little under
the weather this morning.
I was like, you get out of bed right now
(The Chicks chuckling)
'cause The Chicks are
coming and I'm so excited
y'all are here.
But two years ago you
changed your band name
and it took me a minute
y'all 'cause I was like
so used to it from childhood.
But then, I heard that this was something
that y'all kinda had in the
making for a while, right?
- Yeah.
- What was so important to you
to change it to just The Chicks?
- Well, I think just after
George Floyd and all of that,
we wanted to get rid of
the Dixie part of our name
for a long time, but it seemed
like a huge thing to do.
So we would call, even now
our merch would say DCX
and we always referred to
ourselves as The Chicks.
So it seemed like a really natural change
and it seemed kinda seamless.
- Here's what was cool is
you like educated a lot of us
as well because I had no
idea that it meant anything.
So I had to like goo-,
I was like, wait, what?
And I was like googling and it
was interesting to find out,
kind of the origin of
that word and like that.
- Yeah, I think we did the same.
I always thought it was a region.
Like if it's, what direction
- South of Mason-Dixon.
- Yeah. Me too.
So it was interesting though.
I thought that was a really cool
to educate the public though on something,
especially at such an important time.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- So I thought it was really
cool that y'all had done that.
And also it's just like easier to say.
(The Chicks laughing)
so that's awesome.
I'm lazy but I love
and then I think everybody
would always say that too.
Oh, did you see The Chicks?
Did you see the concert?
- Right.
- Everybody would always call y'all that.
- Yeah.
- I think super fans like me.
So what do you each remember
from like the very first time
that y'all played together?
Was it like awkward
or like you knew right
away it was gonna work?
- Well, Natalie had joined
the band, a previous lineup
and so Martie and I were very like nervous.
Like, well she rehearsed all the songs
and know all the songs.
Natalie was just like,
"oh I got this y'all."
(Natalie laughs)
She had this confidence
and Martie and I are just like, oh my gosh!
But Natalie brought this humongous pad
with her lyrics on it
and we just flip it in between songs.
- We played in these two
clubs, outside of Houston.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I would just
(The Chicks laughing)
bend down, turn the page.
- Oh my God. Do you have a
problem with lyrics? I do.
- No, but I had to learn
22 songs in seven days.
I would just listen with headphones
- And learn to yodel.
- And walk around.
Yeah, I had never yodeled before.
(The Chicks laughing)
- That's a lot.
- [Natalie] I know.
- Oh my gosh!
So the band was famously,
had to be reminded of this.
The band was famously
boycotted on country radio,
19 years ago which feels
like forever ago to me.
But it happened after Natalie,
you spoke out against the war in Iraq
and the president in 2003, right?
So what did you, I ended up,
it was "Shut Up and Sing", right?
The documentary that
came out. I loved that.
I think a lot of artists or anybody
that's under a microscope,
I'm jumping straight to that.
I'm gonna ask the question, but
I'm jumping straight to that
because when you're under a
microscope, everything you say
even if you don't mean something some way,
or even if it's in a moment,
everything gets blown out, good or bad.
And it's a very hard way to live
and especially being in an industry,
like I've been told to shut up and sing
and not have an opinion.
And it's very hard 'cause you're a human
and we all count, our
thoughts and our hearts count.
So how did y'all deal with that?
That had to be hard after
watching that "Shut Up and Sing".
That was hard.
Not only on y'all but the
people around you, right?
- Yeah, I don't know.
I'm a fighter, so I
- [Kelly] I gather
- like crumble.
(crowd applauding)
- That's a Texas woman.
- I did crumble.
After we won all the Grammy's,
I kinda fell apart after that.
I think I was just like in this fight mode
and then it all sort
of came crashing down.
- Yeah. It's a lotta weight to carry.
- Yeah and it was for how it
was affecting other people.
I didn't care how it was affecting me.
- [Kelly] That's what I'm saying.
- But, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- I'm so stunned, I just
can't believe I'm here.
I remember it's funny, I
was having this moment.
We were talking about
'cause the first time we
met, it was on Leno, I think.
- Yeah.
- And we were both being interviewed
and I was like I'm on
the same couch with him.
And then now you're like on
my couch, I'm interviewing,
I'm just having a moment.
(The Chicks laughing)
Okay. So you're finally
getting back out on the road.
A lot of artists are being able
to get back out on the road
because of the pandemic,
obviously people couldn't.
So what are some cities
that you're excited to play
like where are you like super stoked?
- Well.
(Natalie and Martie laughing)
Hartford, Connecticut.
- [Kelly] Are you?
- Would be one, yes.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- We have a lot of
family in the Northeast.
- [Kelly] Oh, I didn't know that.
- we have a lot of Connecticut--
- [Kelly] Ties.
- Connections. Yes.
- I love Connecticut
connections as soon are there.
- [Emily] Cut that out.
- Clever girl, I know.
I always get excited.
There are certain shows I love playing.
Yeah. If my family is there
or just some audiences are amazing.
Like New York's always
an amazing audience.
- The state of Ohio is amazing.
- Yeah.
(The Chicks laughing)
Do you know what I find? This is true.
Any state that is hardcore sports ball.
Like if they're sports fans,
like if you're like Man Boston,
that's a fun show to play.
Like they love sports.
They just, they're very passionate people.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- So that's true. Ohio is like that.
- Ohio.
- My executive producer's from there.
She's gonna love that.
So the tour is for your album, Gaslighter.
A lot of people relate to this album
and the message, I guess from
an artist's point of view,
like how hard is it asking for a friend
while I'm currently writing
through a similar situation
is how hard is that to write
so openly and so honest
while navigating children,
while navigating people?
You're under a microscope
like there's so much?
I feel like I've written
so many songs myself
for my personal life.
and I keep kinda keep
going, oh! should I do that?
Or oh God! Did you go through that
like while writing this?
- I definitely wanted to be very blatant
and like literal with this one.
But yeah, I wasn't like
beyond all the emotion
like I am now.
And then there's a stress of,
oh my gosh! Now my kids
are gonna hear this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Now my son is on tour with us.
He's in the band and I'm
like, this is kinda weird.
(audience applauding)
(The Chicks laughing)
I'm always checking. Are you okay?
Are you all right?
- Oh my God. I know, 'cause
that could be awkward.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- But I love the fact
that like he's an artist.
So he does get the fact that
like it's very therapeutic
for us to like, that's our outlet.
- There's no way around it.
When you write falsely, it doesn't work.
- It's transparent that
you're full of crap, yeah.
- [Emily] You have to be real.
- Agreed. Sorry I'm so blunt.
(audience laughing)
- It's weird. The more specific you are,
the more it's universal to other people.
(audience applauding)
- Which, isn't that so sad?
- Yeah, I know.
- I mean life is so hard.
Yeah. It's sad that people relate.
Okay. So we all went through divorces.
And how did you each find
strength and not just music?
I think it's therapeutic, but
like your female friendships.
I feel like that has really helped me.
- Yeah. I remember when
you first came down
in the studio in Nashville and said,
"Guys, I just wanna tell
you I'm getting a divorce."
- Which time was this?
(The Chicks laughing)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my gosh!
- It's the first one. Number One.
I remember thinking, well,
I'm getting a divorce.
Now, she says, she's getting a divorce.
Now, I can't say I'm getting a divorce.
It was kind but then I(indistinct)
- but me saying it.
- You haven't told her.
- I hadn't told y'all.
I was feeling like
everybody was gonna judge me
'cause I was like I thought I
was first getting the divorce.
- [Kelly] You Kept that in!
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- So I was like, guys,
I'm getting a divorce.
And Martie's like, I'm
having a horrible marriage.
(The Chicks laughing)
- Oh my Gosh.
- We'll do this together because I felt,
'cause I didn't know anybody close to me
that was getting a divorce,
so I was so happy for you.
- Yeah, we were divorced buddies.
- But it is something to talk about
'cause there is a level of like shame,
and like guilt and people
especially from where we're from.
It's like you stick it out and it's like,
oh, that's what I've been doing, you know?
And I dunno if I can do it.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
I dunno if I can continue
that for both of you.
Like obviously it's not working
and people aren't happy.
So it's a hard thing.
I can't imagine holding that in.
Like I had to finally,
I can't imagine holding it in for a while
and then you finally say it.
But the release of that is so monumental.
I don't know, I felt like
it was for me. Did you?
- Oh yeah. But I didn't
have kids with that one
and she didn't either.
And I think it's so much harder
when you've got your babies.
- Yeah, it is. That's where
the decision making sucks.
So what does it mean to
have your kids performing
with you on this tour
'cause that's pretty cool?
- It's awesome.
Slade's 21. He can play everything.
- [Kelly] Could drink legally.
- Bit right, isn't it?
(The Chicks laughing)
I don't worry about that.
And Martie's daughter's gonna play
- [Martie] She's 18
- [Natalie] Violin.
She plays piano and violin.
- Wow.
- But she's gonna play violin,
maybe try some accordion.
But I wanna say Slade is
just as good as anybody
in the band. It's not a charity case.
(The Chicks laughing)
- You're on a kid of bone,
like this kid is, he's amazing.
- That's so cool. What
does that mean for you
just to have like your kids
kinda doing what you do,
like that influenced
them. That's so amazing.
- Makes me really proud and really happy
because he made the decision
not to go to college,
so he's got a job.
(The Chicks laughing)
(audience applauding)
he's on his way.
- It's better than college, it is.
People always ask me though
about my kids are like,
oh, can they sing? I'm like, well, yeah,
but like I'm not gonna push them this way.
Like 'cause sometimes this,
you know that the industry
can be very difficult
and very hard and it's kind
of a scary thing to be like,
yes, it's very fun and creative
and there's this awesome side of it.
But there's also a lot of sacrifice
and there's also a lot of just
hardship that comes with it
that we don't allow people to see
'cause nobody wants to
see that part right?
- Yeah. But I don't think
when you're as good as
like Martie, Emily or Slade,
it's the no brainer.
There's nothing else. That's
what you're going to do.
That is what you are meant to do.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He would be wasting time
if that's not what he was going for.
There's just nothing else that he--
- Oh, I love that. The confidence
into it. That's awesome.
- [Natalie] Yeah.
- All right.
I can't imagine like turning
around and River or Remi.